[Music]
the live audience doesn't intimidate you
right not a bit okay you came from very
modest circumstances modest is not the
word very few people in the world are
known by one name they started me with a
campaign called what is an Oprah you're
a big shareholder in Weight Watchers
that is a sign when Weight Watchers says
let us help
you have you ever thought you could
actually run for president I thought oh
gee I don't have the experience I don't
know enough I don't know and now I'm
thinking
oh would you fix your tith please well
people wouldn't recognize me if my tie
was fixed but okay just leave it this
way all
[Music]
right I don't consider myself a
journalist and nobody else would
consider myself a journalist I began to
take on the life of being an interviewer
even though I have a day job of running
a private Equity
Firm how do you define
leadership what is it that makes
somebody
[Music]
tick tweet tweet
hello well the live audience doesn't
intimidate you right not a bit okay I
feel right at home actually it's the one
thing I miss from The Daily Show you
know every from now every now and then
somebody will say do you miss miss the
show no I don't miss the show what I
miss is is the people is the camaraderie
because what I did every day
is have my own after show with the
audience so I would talk to the audience
probably half an hour to 40 minutes
after every show starting 10 years in
because at first I did autographs every
day and I'd stand there by Road and I do
the autographs and never look up trying
to get through 350 right and then one
day I decided oh gee I don't want to do
that anymore but what do I really want
to do I want to talk to this audience I
want to find out who they are where they
come from so I started like talking to
them 10 years in and that became my
favorite part of the day wow yeah it was
my own personal focus group it's the
reason why we were number one for 25
years because I use the information that
I gathered every day from people who
were the the greatest resource they were
the people who were viewers who had
taken the time to come with their aunts
and daughters and cousins and a few
husbands who'd be like well I came to
Oprah so that's going to be good for at
least two months yeah for something that
show was on for 25 years in Chicago and
um when you did it you won I think
almost 50 Emmy Awards and it was voted
one of the best TV shows in the history
of TV so you ended it though after 25
years to do other things and we'll talk
about that but you no regrets about
ending that show no no reg no regrets
whatsoever you know I I didn't want to
be punch drunk
in the ring still trying to uh come up
with what is the next thing what is the
next thing because over the years we
became our own greatest competition so
when I first started uh went National in
1986 every time there would be another
talk show be oh haraldo River oh what
are we going to do and then I realized a
couple of years in that you run your own
race better than anybody if you take the
time to see what everybody else is doing
you lose your ground and that I could be
a better me than I could be anybody else
and so no need of trying to compare
myself to other people so once I got
that we hit our own Rhythm and also once
I discovered that it wasn't just a show
but that it was a platform in which to
speak to the world and then uh that was
about ' 89 when I thought okay what do
you want to say to the world how do you
want to be used and not have the TV use
you but how do I want to use it what
drives you to keep working so hard you
could you know you and I are in the 60s
category and so when you're in your 60s
you know you've lived more than you're
going to live realistically so when you
realize you've lived more than you're
going to live you can say why not relax
a little bit why not just ease up why
have you decided to even work harder
than you did before because I think
David that everybody you know the thing
that worked for me all these years
whether it was the magazine or which I
still have or whether it was the show I
could I understood that there's a common
denominator in The Human Experience and
I want the same thing you want which is
the same thing you want and you want
what we all want is to be able to live
out the
truest highest expression of ourselves
as a human being that doesn't end until
you take your last breath what is the
truest highest Vision that you hold for
yourself no matter where you are in your
life there's always the next level
there's always the Next Level to the
last breath so I feel that I always knew
that I would get be done with the show
when I felt like oh I've said as much as
I could say here on this platform and
then how will I be used if there were if
there were a theme song to my life
Amazing Grace would be one of them and
keep on using me till you use me up
would be another
one you know that bill Wither
song so I feel that until you have used
your value as a human being you're not
done okay so today um if you look back
on what you've achieved already and
let's suppose you got a long way to go
before you're finished achieving
everything what would you say are the
greatest Pleasures that you have
received or what you're most proud of
okay so the th these are good thank you
this is good all right this is good
while I watch your interview show so I
know how to do some
interviews um I think the thing that I
am most proud of reminds me of uh uh
when I had I had done my school in South
Africa I have a school in South Africa
of girls and I wanted to create this
girl
and um this is just celebrated 10th
anniversary just celebrated 10th
anniversary I've got girls from brown to
Stanford to Elon all over the United
States going to school I have 10
graduations to attend in
2017 um but I remember when I started
the school and I said to my uh beloved
uh friend Maya Angelo I said Maya I'm so
I'm so just so proud that I was able to
create this school and I said this is
going to be my greatest Legacy and Maya
said to me you have no
idea right
right you have no idea what your legacy
will be she said to me because your
legacy is every life you've touched and
that shifted the way I saw Legacy or
what you leave behind or what you do cuz
Maya was explaining to me that you know
over all the years years of watching
your show everybody who decided that
they were going to go back to school or
lose weight or no longer hit their
children or get out of a bad marriage
all of those people who have seen and
experienced your voice and the same
thing with everybody here you have no
idea what your legacy will be your
legacy is every life that you've touched
and we like to think of it I know you
have done amazing things with your
philanthropy we like to think that these
great philanthropic moments the ones
that leave the impact or will make the
huge difference in the world but it's
really what you do every day it's how
you use your life to be a light to
somebody else's you know and it's how
you use your work as an expression of
your own art whatever that is so I don't
I I I think I would say the girls as I
get to watch them now graduate from
college and move into their lives but
really there is a moment that that
happened to me
um just about a year after I went
National there was a woman in Ann Arbor
Michigan who wrote me a letter that will
go on my well I'm not going to have a
tombstone but if I had a tombstone
wasn't cremated it would go there um she
said Oprah watching you be yourself
every day makes me want to be more of
myself and I just don't know of anything
better than that so I am most proud of
and just yesterday I went to see uh
notes from the field with aned Smith and
in the bathroom this woman comes up to
me and says you know I've watched you
all these years and you did so much for
me and I used to just hear people say oh
I watch your show I love you I love you
I watch your show and about 10 years in
about the time I started talking to the
audience I would stop people and say so
tell me what is it what what is it that
moved you why why do you love the show
why do you and this woman said to me
just yesterday you helped me to be more
of myself so is so that's my that's
being Oprah is it hard to go to the
bathroom in these public places people
are I mean isn't that kind of
challenging at times as a matter of fact
it was because there was another lady
attacking me because I she thought I
didn't do enough for Mrs Clinton so then
so so somebody else came out of a stall
this is yesterday and said leave Oprah
alone she's just trying to pee right
okay so did they follow that advice or
no okay and she followed me out talking
about what I could have done should have
done blah blah blah very few people in
the world are known by one name Oprah
there's Elvis there's Jesus very few
people um and it's only when I was
challenged with the idea of changing it
that I thought no I'm going to keep my
name you think about what you've
accomplished you came from very modest
circumstances you didn't come from a
wealthy family well modest is not the
word well I was trying to be polite I
mean I was I was actually poor and I you
know a lot of the girls at my school
actually all the girls from my school
are poor and I was saying to them just
recently I was just in South Africa for
a graduation you know you all are come
come from the same circumstances you
were poor and one of the girls raised
her hand and said I don't like using
that word I go well if you're not poor
then you should excuse yourself because
that's why I'm paying for you because
you're schol so if you're not but you
don't like the choice of the word so I
don't I don't have a problem with the
word I don't have any Shame about it I
think you know probably earlier in my
life or career the word would have
bothered me but it truly it was it it it
was I was poor no running water David or
electricity living with an
ouse okay that's poor but you were also
shuttled between your mother your father
your grandmother and so forth it's very
disconcerting to be shuttled back and
forth so at what point did you realize
that you had some skills that were maybe
going to enable you to rise up when you
were young you had some pretty good
skills as an order well I think
kindergarten I kind of felt it I was
uh did other people agree with you then
that you were going to be special no
this is my kindergarten Sor Listen My
Grandmother Had taught me so I'm raised
on this little acre I used to call it a
farm then I went back and saw it it
wasn't a farm right it was an acre um
and I remember uh my grandmother taught
me how to read so I grew up learning
learning to learning to read and read
Bible verses that's I grew up reading so
by the time I was six and got shuttled
to Milwaukee and cuz my birthday came in
the wrong time I I hadn't the the the
grace for me is that I didn't spend a
day in a segregated school so I did not
have one moment of ever being
conditioned to believe that I was less
than anybody so when I walked into my
first uh kindergarten class first time
I'd ever seen little white children that
my grandmother didn't you know work for
and everybody was doing their ABC things
and I was like why are the children
doing the
ABCs so I wrote my kindergarten teacher
Miss new a letter and I said Dear Miss
new I do not belong here
right so because I know a lot of big
words and then I proceeded to write
every big word I knew any anybody who
reads a Bible here it was Shadrach meak
abedo Nehemiah Jeremiah and then I put
in elephant and hippopotamus just
because there were some more big words
so I I kind of then I saw the impression
that made on Miss new speaking of big
words in Bible your your first name came
from a Biblical um Source but it was
supposed to be orpa orpa how did it get
to be Oprah uh misspelled the first day
I went to school and it stayed that way
so it's on my birth certificate as orpa
but it's now very famous very few people
in the world are known by one name Oprah
there's Elvis there's Jesus very few
people um but but I mean there a few
others but suppose your name was just
Mary or Jane it wouldn't have worked it
would work okay and I remember once
being uh in Baltimore and I had a news
director who when I first came to work
in Baltimore had said to me we're going
to have to do something about that name
we need to do something about that cuz
nobody's going to remember it or know
how to pronounce it and up until that
time David I'd always wanted to have a
name like everybody else's so it was
only when when uh my bosses told me that
you know I was going to I needed to
think about changing it and they
mentioned you know Susie cuz Susie's
friendly that nobody can say Susie and
not mean not say Susie Susie Winfrey
Eyewitness News uh that that's a
friendly thing and it's only when I was
um challenged with the idea of changing
it that I thought no I'm going to keep
my name so when I started in Baltimore
your mother can tell you this cuz she
was there they they started me with a
campaign called what is an Oprah trying
to explain to people how to pronounce
the name and and and and well so those
who may not know your background you
went to college in Tennessee yeah and
then you worked briefly in a Tennessee
broadcasting operation and then you were
recruited to go to Baltimore my hometown
and what you're referring to is that my
mother used to watch you and she would
call me up and say there's a terrific
person on a show here she's going
National I said well really come on
people in Baltimore don't usually go
National but uh she was right your
mother knew I know she was smart you
should listen to your mother so when you
went to Baltimore you went initially to
be a an anchor woman and then didn't
quite work out yeah I got fired well you
well demoted I was got demoted but they
didn't they had a contract so they
didn't say goodbye and then how did you
work out to be on a uh afternoon show
where you actually got to be an
interviewer how did that actually happen
well what happened was they they this is
how this is what what I now know with
age and perspective that many times
getting
demoted is an opportunity for something
else to show up or getting fired you
know a lots of people I've interviewed
over the years who have these stories
about the best thing that ever happened
to you it puts you in the next best
place I was not a good television
reporter I was too emotional I would go
out on the stories and you know then try
to take blankets back to the people
you're also very young you were you were
21 I was very also athetic and and I was
always getting written up for getting
myself involved in other people's
business and so um I was making
$22,000 a year and my best friend Gail
who I met there at the time she was uh
also working there and um she said oh my
God you're 22 making 22,000 imagine when
you're
25 then you're 30 so I'd be making 60
about now it be good 62 and um
glad that didn't work out yeah but uh we
were we were uh we once I got demoted
they didn't want to pay out my contract
I was making $225,000 a year they didn't
want to pay me the 25,000 so they kept
me on and said we'll put you on this
talk show just to run out your contract
and the person who wanted to demote you
has that person risen in the broadcast
world as a matter of fact they did they
moved on and did worked out when did you
realize that you actually had a skill as
an interviewer my skill comes from my
listening ability what gave me the power
in the seat and the power with the
microphone was I always saw myself as
the surrogate for the
audience
the show worked very well and all of a
sudden your contract is up for Renewal
and then somebody comes along and says
how about a show in Chicago why don't
you do a show in Chicago and you decided
to leave is that right I decided to
leave my contract really wasn't up at
the time but um I started feeling like I
think everybody knows I I've I I've
moved my whole life on Instinct you know
I feel like now it's time to let the
show go I feel like it's time to move on
because I've grown as much as I can grow
when I've grown as much as I can grow in
a space that's my instinct to move so I
started to feel like I needed to move
someplace else New York felt too um
crowded too hard to get around it was
the number one market everybody wanted
to come here as a matter of fact I had
an agent at the time and I said to the
agent I just want to be a substitute for
Joan London remember Joan London I said
could you just get me a you know a job
as the substitute for Joan London when
she goes on vacation and maybe she wants
to take a break and that agent said to
me that's never going to happen because
they've already got one black person and
I said really and they said he said yes
Bryant Gumble I said it's the wrong
station it's on another he's on another
station so maybe they would take one
more over but he he said no not that's
not going to work out so I let that
agent go and I ended up uh going to
Chicago because I was on somebody else's
uh audition tape
one of my producers had gone there she
called me up and she said Dennis Swanson
just saw you on my tape she was she she
had been hired as a producer and he
wants to know uh would you be interested
in doing a job here called am Chicago
that's how that happened so you got
there and it was an existing show and
you took it over and all of a sudden it
became pretty popular in fact they
changed the name to the Oprah Winfrey
Show because people started calling the
oah show did you see the opah show today
opah show so they weren't calling a
Chicago and this is the thing every
single person other than my friend Gail
who was still in Baltimore had said to
me you're going to fail in Chicago
because I was going to be going up
against Phil Don everybody said Phil who
Phil yes I was going to be
going and you know it didn't matter to
me because I did not think that he was
beatable and I actually said it to the
my boss Dennis Swanson who's gone on to
do great things in television Dennis
Swanson said we know you can't beat him
so don't worry about it just be yourself
and that saved me because had had had
imagine little chubby me with a Jerry
Carl uh right being told now you've got
to go and you've got to beat Phil Don
here we were he said we're just a local
show here and so if you can get a number
we'll take it and and so I had no press
pressure I had no pressure so I just
went on the air and I was myself so he
ultimately left Chicago and moved to New
York because of the competition I guess
I'm not sure and ultimately you well we
beat I beat him David I did right right
right know well I uh I did beat him I
did I wasn't trying to I wasn't even
trying to but you know it's just like um
I'm sympathetic to white men with white
hair but uh but uh but you you did you
did very well well he he actually was so
gracious and I often I have always said
had there not been a filon there
couldn't have been an Oprah Show because
he paved the way for that kind of
audience you know smart women at home
many of them stay-at-home mothers taking
care of their kids some of them going
back into the workforce in the uh mid
80s when I started um who were
interested in talking about uh
purposeful things meaningful things so
he open that door when did you realize
in Chicago or Baltimore that you
actually had a skill as an interviewer
that was really better than anybody else
and where do you think that skill came
from I never thought it was better than
anybody else's what I do think I have
that is really uniquely my own is my
ability to connect to the audience
because my skill comes not from my
interviewing ability my skill comes from
my listening ability and my skill comes
from me
knowing
fundamentally inside myself that I am no
different than the audience so what gave
me the power in the seat and the power
with the microphone was I always saw
myself as the surrogate for the audience
so I would ask people questions that I
would not normally ask I mean I asked
some really embarrassing qu embarrassing
question once not cuz I wanted to know
the answer but because I thought the
audience did and then I thought I'm not
going to ask what the audience wants the
next time and when I get in that
situation it was a it was a I I put
myself in a bad situ I asked Sally Field
when she was dating Bert Reynolds
I asked remember this Gil I asked Sally
F did Bert sleep with his toue
on what was the answer or the
question and I would never do that today
I wouldn't do it because I was doing it
because I was getting pushed by The
Producers like people want to know
people want to know so I was thinking I
was doing it on behalf of the audience
she shut
down and I could see that it embarrassed
her and I never got another thing from
her so I thought okay that that was
wrong I learned from that so while you
were there doing the show you got an
opportunity to be an actress in The
Color Purple yes and what was well not
just an
opportunity oh Lord I don't even have
time for this story because I never
wanted anything more in my life David
and I haven't wanted anything as much
since as much as I wanted the color
purple I'd read the book uh I'd seen a
review in the New York Times so I
started hearing that they were going to
do a movie long story short I auditioned
for the movie and uh only because Quincy
Jones happened to be happened no such
thing as happen Sans Quincy Jones was
going through Chicago My little show am
Chicago was on they were looking for an
actress to play this part I did not know
Quincy Jones he is coming out of his
shower after taking the red eyee he is
there for a a deposition cuz he's
testifying on behalf of Michael
for somebody who said you know Billy
Jean was their lover or whatever and U
so he's there in Chicago he's coming out
of the shower the TV set is on and he
sees me on AM Chicago and he thinks I
think that girl could be in the movie so
he tells his people who call me I had
been praying and hoping to be in this
movie The Color Purple and I get a call
one day I'm just in the in the my office
and uh the casting agent says I'm
calling about a movie we're
doing uh would you be interested in
coming to audition the movie's called
moons song and I said well I wasn't
praying for a movie called moons
song I was praying for a movie called
The Color Purple could this be the color
purple he said no the movie's called
moonsong because at the time that's what
they were all calling it cuz it stevenh
didn't want people to know he was doing
it I went and audition for it and I knew
of course it was it was the Quincy was
the producer and St workor and so you
got the part I got the part I love
hoo God knows I
do but I kill him dead for I let him
beat me you were nominated for an
Academy Award and you should have won
but didn't win that year right but it's
okay the dress didn't fit and I wouldn't
have been able to get out of the chair
anyway so
thanks was that hard to give give up
Chicago I don't feel sad at all I feel a
great sense of pride Pride I think that
what we were able to do with that show
every day I'm just proud of the work and
then I realized it's time to let that
go let's talk about uh your show you
ended the show in 2011 mm but slightly
around that time you decided you were
going to build uh the O WN which is open
W Network Network and that was a joint
venture between you and Discovery
Channel and you were still doing your
show in Chicago and all of a sudden they
say let's do a a network and so you're
still in finishing the show and the
network is starting so it didn't go as
well as you would have liked in the in
the beginning but then you finished your
show and it turned out worked out pretty
well now it's doing very well doing very
well we have really some really great
successful shows on there and um I I
partnered with du this past year uh to
create this uh drama series called Queen
sugar right right another drama series
called Green Green Leaf so I am now able
to it's the next level for me every day
on my show for 25 years I was
the Storyteller helping people to let
their stories out into the world in such
a way that enhanced them or helped them
see themselves differently or or however
it showed up for them and now I get to
use drama the the the platform of drama
uh to create stories that allow people
particularly African-American people to
see and feel themselves in a way that
shows us uh as people of value as people
who care about the things that everybody
else cares about you know the one thing
I was always trying to do through all of
my work particularly all those years of
the Oprah Winfrey show was to let people
see
uh what Maya always said is that we
really are more alike than we are
different and that when you get into
somebody's home and you're sitting
around the kitchen table I don't care
who you are or what your K kitchen table
looks like or how many square feet you
have that the feelings are the same that
we find our deepest Humanity at that
kitchen table and when you open the door
and I look in your house and your house
which I used to do on the Oprah show
used to just love going in people's
houses like I just wonder what they're
doing for dinner and then dropping in
and say hey so um to do the to do the
own you basically moved from Chicago
where you have been living for 25 years
moved to the West Coast yes that's right
and was that hard to give give up
Chicago or you didn't mind no I think
everybody has to particularly you know
this having hit 60 there comes a point
and I'm really I'm really good at this
is at at not holding on to what was and
being able to live in this present
moment you know I never was one of those
women who's afraid to tell your age or
you're trying to be something you're not
I mean I think for everything there's a
time and a season uh the Bible
completely right about that I think I
think um and you know in your own self
when it's time to move from that I
remember last year we were going through
the building and I was going through
with Gail who's been with me through
everything and Gail's like I feel sad
don't you feel sad and I said I don't I
don't feel sad at all I feel a great
sense of Pride I think that what we were
able to do with that show every day um
sitting really in the in in the heart of
America uh allowing people to see the
best and sometimes the worst of
themselves through their neighbors and
dysfunction and ideas that we brought to
them child and um I I'm just proud of
the work and then I realized it's time
to let that go so no I don't I don't
feel that at all the only thing was hard
was uh when the building came down I
sold the building which was really like
a campus there were five buildings and
when that first main building came down
and somebody instagrammed it that's the
only time I had a like it's really
happening you know but it's no different
than have you ever gone back to your
house where you used to live and there
there's and the house is gone well I
went back to my childhood home not too
long ago with my mother for a TV show
and I knocked on the door and I said can
we come in I used to live here a long
time ago and they called the police uh
they they uh they thought I was a robber
or something anyway um so you mentioned
a couple times Gail and Gail King is
here she's your best friend and tell me
how do you maintain a friendship when
you live in such different cities all
the time and youve maintained it over a
long period of time yeah since those
days in Baltimore since we were 21 and
22 and I say to my girls at my
school you wish yourself they call her
auntie Gail and M M I said you all wish
to have a friend like Auntie Gail you
want to have a friend who wants the most
the best and the highest for you I have
never seen a person like Gail I
never yeah you know everybody especially
if you uh are on the rise in your career
and you have had certain friends and
they all act like they're happy for you
but not everybody's happy for you and
every now and then you can hear just a
teen NY bit of jealousy you can hear it
can sense it I've never had a moment's
jealousy from Gail in you know the 30
odd years of her friendship except for
the one time I was on stage dancing with
Tina Turner
right that's the only time I ever heard
Gil goes I wish that was
me people call you all the time and say
give me money for this give me money for
that don't pay attention to that helping
girls because I was a poor girl and I
know what that feels like I can it
resonates in my
spirit you've been very public over the
years about your weight issues and now
you're a big shareholder in Weight
Watchers so how have you um kind of deal
with the weight issues over the years
you've I tried to let that work for me
you know actually Weight Watchers call
me up and uh as I said I don't do
anything that doesn't feel truthful or
organic or or like how can so they're
asking me to be a spokesperson and I
said well I've never been on the program
I've always thought the people who had
to count points I don't know about those
people and uh but the fact that Weight
Watchers were was calling me that's how
bad it got that Weight Watchers call so
you know that is a sign when Weight
Watcher says let us help
you right
you go look in the mirror go oh I see
what you're talking about okay um so I I
was just doing what I always do and that
is not just trying to be a spokesperson
but listen how can I own a piece of it
because since the days of the Oprah
Winfrey show you know that worked out
for me U uh the biggest great greatest
decision I made with the Oprah show was
to own it myself so the very first year
that we came up for renegotiation for a
contract
because my bosses at ABC had given me a
really hard time when I was doing the
color purple they had said to me you
only have two weeks vacation and I
wanted to do that movie more than
anything I in my life and I said to them
I will give up my entire contracts
vacation and if you will just let me do
the movie so I had a really smart
attorney at the time Jeff Jacobs who
said you never want to be in that
position again where you have to give up
yourself give up your life so when the
the contract negotiation came around the
second time I said what if I own the
show and you don't pay me unless the
show makes money and we make money
together so let's split it so I I
approach everything that way if I'm
going to be of value to you it should
also be of value to myself you um are
now the CEO of your company you're the
owner and the CEO and you've got
thousands of people working for you yeah
and as a CEO do you have to say no to
people all the time and is that hard to
do uh you get other people who say no
for you um saying no is hard that is one
of the big big lessons life lessons for
me I I I grew up obviously girl uh
raised in the South women need to please
wanting to please everybody so it took
me a long time to get that lesson of
only saying yes to what you intend to
say yes to and and so uh I tried to do
all of my business decisions and
personal decisions based upon
my intention when you um develop the
success you've had what comes along with
it in our society is money yeah and uh
when you make as much money as you have
made and I've been fortunate to make as
well you really can't spend it all
yourself no matter how much you want to
buy a new plane or new but you can try
you can try but it's it's it's tough you
can have a really good time trying it's
tough It's it's uh it's tough yeah I me
how many things can you really buy so
you can you talk about your philanthropy
how you decide to give away money and by
the way you just recently became the
largest donor to the uh Museum of
African-American history and culture in
Washington why thank you for that I
agreed to be on that board over 13 years
ago because I believe you are nowhere in
life unless you know where you've come
from and that understanding the the true
root of what has been paved for you is
necessary for uh a people to move
forward so I wanted to leave the legacy
of that for generations to come
particularly for africanamerican
children but also for people of all
Races to understand who we are as a
people and as a culture and what that
has meant to uh America so now you
decide how to give away money by virtue
of a foundation you have a staff how do
you decide I want you give money to that
no I don't have a staff I don't I do
have a foundation and I do have people
working there but I just nobody tells me
okay but people call you all the time
and say give me money for this give me
money for that pay attention to that I
don't pay any attention to that so in
the beginning I used to in the beginning
David I was so overwhelmed by it because
I couldn't figure out when your salaries
published in the paper how much money
you make and everybody knows it so you
can no longer say I don't have it I
couldn't figure it out I was like people
were leaving home leaving their husbands
boarding trains coming to see me I had
people standing outside my door in
Chicago and I was like overwhelmed by it
and then I uh started to I mean I got
lots of advice for lots of people about
what to do I now only do what I intend
that comes from what is important to me
so helping girls because I was a poor
girl and I know what that feels like I
can it resonates in my spirit I know
that when you change a girl's life you
not only change hers but you change her
entire Community because girls give back
to the family give back to the community
so saving girls around the world is
really important to me educating girls
and women and empowering girls and women
cuz I am one myself feels like a natural
thing have you ever thought that given
the popularity you have that you could
actually uh run for president and
actually be
elected I thought OG I don't have the
experience I don't know enough I don't
know now I'm thinking
oh all right
[Applause]
okay let me ask you a question about
politics um you avoided politics
throughout your career and you had no
politici on your show you said they were
not really what you wanted to do and
then somebody named Barack Obama was
running for president in
2008 and you said I'm going to violate
my principle and I'm going to endorse
him and it seemed to work out it helped
them a great deal you might say I think
interestingly enough it wasn't the kind
of thing again I operate from what feels
like the right thing to do you would be
stunned at how little I thought about
was it the right thing or what it was
going to cost me I did it because I felt
compelled to do it I felt from the time
I saw him at uh in 2004 at the
convention and I was in Chicago and I'd
seen him as a senator around and I saw
that like everybody else did that
convention in 2004 and I remember I was
alone in my uh house and I thought he's
going to be president someday and I hope
I'm around to help him do it so I
started telling him in 2004 and five
when you run for president let me know
when you run for president let me know I
had a group of African-Americans at my
house who had all been really uh major
Legends for me so I had this big part I
I like having parties so I was a big
party and I had like Diana Ross and sicy
Tyson and Maya and caretta King and all
of these wonderful legendary women to
thank them for Paving the way for me and
then I had a bunch of youngans like uh
Mariah and Janet and all of those groups
to also help me thank them and I had
Barack Obama come to my house and speak
in 2005 where I had all these people
there and I said to that group in 2005
this man is going to be president of the
United States someday and I'm going I
hope I'm alive when it happens and if I
am I will do whatever I can in my power
I'll quit my job I'll go work for him
I'll canvas for him I'll do and they
said what's his name again that
was what what his name again that was in
2005 so it wasn't uh I just I felt like
this is something I can do did some of
your your viewers criticize you for
getting on politics major criticis
criticism and I was surprised by it
actually cuz I had I was only surprised
by it cuz I'd never thought about it it
didn't occur to me that people didn't
know that I voted one way or the other
so the first night he was uh inaugurated
2009 January 20th 2009 so upstairs at
the White House you were invited to the
residen and what was it like how you
know well I know okay and uh so I was
wondering what it was like here
African-Americans are in the residence
of the White House the president's
African-American and this is a house
that's built by slaves and what was the
emotion like that first night you're you
got somebody elected president United
United States you helped him get elected
and what was it like that first night it
was Indescribable I don't think that
there are actually words that could um I
thought I heard Dave Chappelle actually
on um Saturday Night Live talking about
looking over and seeing a party recently
wasn't the same I don't think as is as
uh inaugural night it was kind of it
felt surreal and obviously you're
looking at all the paintings on the wall
of past presidents uh and leaders who
were all white it it it was it was we
could just kind of I remember walking
out afterwards it was Gail stemman
Gail's kid we were all like did that
just happen did that it was it was it
felt surreal Barack Obama was the first
African-American to be elected president
and now we've had somebody elected
president who was a media figure you
might argue um now um we've never had a
woman elected president United States so
have you ever thought that given the
popularity you have we haven't broken
the glass last ceiling yet for women
that you could actually run for
president and actually be
[Applause]
elected
I I I actually never thought that that
was I never considered the question even
a possibility I just thought
oh oh right because it's clear that you
don't need government experience to be
elected presid United States right I
thought oh gee I don't have the
experience I don't know enough I don't
know now I'm thinking
oh all right well
okay
well now speaking of oh that's the name
of your magazine right yes it is right
right so uh a couple final questions
would wrap up um as you consider whether
you're going to run for president not
United States or not no that won't be
happening but I I mean I did Ed I you
did used to think well you had to know
so much more than I thought you had to
know but
anyway so today uh as you look at what
you're doing your highest priorities are
uh developing own and acting and and
also executive yes I just finished uh
The Immortal Life of Henrietta Lex right
yeah and that's Henry alax's cells were
used in effect for the polio vaccine and
other things and you're and that is her
daughter Deborah Lex wow mhm so are you
going to continue acting as well as I'm
going to continue acting I'm going to
continue developing shows that speak uh
to the humanity of people in a way that
makes them want to live better and do
better and um that exalts their their
their victories and lets them know that
they are important and meaningful in the
world you know I would have to say
that every day David that show was such
a it was like therapy for me kind of
like now uh right every day the show was
I paid attention so I I've never been to
a therapist but uh I I I I paid
attention all those days on the show and
I made therapy acceptable for a lot of
people who thought H not me not so one
of the things I started to
get uh
around mid to late no no late mid to
late 90s is that everybody that I had on
the show at the end of the show would
say something to me like um was that
okay was that okay how was that was that
okay right at the end of the interview
and I started to then track it it didn't
matter if it was um I I I I had gone and
done a show where I was in um a prison
and I was interviewing a father who was
in jail for life for murdering his twin
daughters and at the end of the
interview even Behind Bars he said to me
is that okay how'd I do and Barack Obama
said it when he sat in the chair the
first time and George Bush said it
Beyonce said it at the end of if she
taught me how to twer and then said is
that
okay so that's an acquired skill do they
right yes working thing but this is what
I learned uh sitting in that chair for
25 years that at the end of the day
whether you
are interviewing me or I get to
interview you whatever your profession
is wherever you are in your life in your
relationships every person that you
encounter every experience the person
wants to know was that okay was that
okay and what I started to hear was that
what people are really saying is did you
hear me did you hear me and did what I
say mean anything to you you and so I
started to listen with that in mind with
that intention of validating that you're
being here your speaking to me your
taking the time to do this with me is
important because you matter and that's
true for everybody who's watching or
listening that every argument that you
ever have every encounter the person
just wants to know did you hear me did
you see me and did I say anything that
how do you ever relax now oh I'm so I'm
I I would say the word for me now is
um I'm content I'm not just relaxed I'm
content cuz I know a lot of rich people
who are not happy but I am not one of
them but when you're I am one of the
happiest rich people you are ever going
to
see well when when you're trying to just
when you're trying to get away from it
all and just get away from everything
you just relax at one of your homes or
yes I real well and also it doesn't take
a lot for me to relax I can uh I can be
happy looking at a leaf Gail Gail will
say what are you sitting out under the
trees with your thoughts and I'll say
yeah I'm really I can be happy with a
book I can be happy reading poetry I can
be happy in front of a fire I can be
happy with my dogs I can be yeah crack
me up I don't know why to thank you for
doing this I realize uh one of the great
pleasures of your not life is not being
interviewed by me so I appreciate you
giving me the time to do this it has it
has been a pleasure though thank you and
uh it's my pleasure completely and I
would like to say that I this is a
lowbudget show compared to yours so we
are going to give a car out to everybody
here including you but it's a smaller
car than you usually give out so it's a
little car in here and
uh so it's a car we we we uh our our oh
this is great
so we can't afford a big car but uh
thank you for that that's so cute all
right well thank you very much great
thank
you thank
you